I think probably
everything I say tonight I
have said in several
versions to the students
at New College of the
Humanities in the last few years
when I've given lectures.
They've very much
helped me write
the book that's now emerged.
And I was thinking, just
as you were introducing me,
of a science teacher I
had when I was 16 or so,
who said a wonderful
thing-- a physics teacher.
He said science done right
is one of the humanities.
And I thought, oh,
what a great idea.
And I sort of kept that
in my mind all along.
And when Anthony at New College
of the Humanities asked me--
and, of course,
I'm a philosopher--
to do my thing, I knew
that I was encouraged
to talk about the science
that I was interested in,
the scientific
ideas, which I think
are also important
philosophical ideas.
And that's what I'm going
to talk about tonight.
So thank you all for coming.
If some of you have seen my
Royal Institution talk of about
two years ago, you will
recognise a few slides.
This is a later development
of my thinking and pretty much
lines up with what's
in my new book, called
From Bacteria to Bach and Back.
Here's a sort of punchline.
Should be fairly obvious.
We are the first intelligent
designers in the tree of life.
Now, this is my favourite
diagram of the tree of life.
And if you see, this is
the present all along here.
This is the origin of life.
So time goes out here.
And here are the
earliest life forms,
the bacteria in the Archean.
And here's this
great, great moment,
the eukaryotic revolution, which
led to this wonderful fanning
out of basically all
the living things you
can see with your naked eye.
And that little Y there, well,
that's about six million years.
And that's how long
we've been separated
from our common ancestor
with the chimpanzee.
So human beings have
only been on the scene
for just a tiny little
bit of this diagram.
And I'm claiming that--
is there intelligent design?
Yes.
Intelligent designers in
this room by the dozens.
And our scientists and artists
are intelligent designers.
So the problem then that
I'm facing in this book is,
how did intelligent
designers evolve?
If natural selection is
not intelligent design,
and it isn't, how did small I,
small D intelligent designers
evolve?
And some people
have real trouble,
including somebody who's going
to be here, I understand,
in the next month.
And that's Roger
Penrose, who says
"I am a strong believer in the
power of natural selection.
But I do not see how
natural selection in itself
can evolve algorithms
which could
have the kind of
conscious judgements
of the validity of
other algorithms
that we seem to have."
He goes on, "to my
way of thinking,
there is still something
mysterious about evolution
and its apparent groping
towards some future purpose.
Things at least seem to organise
themselves somewhat better
than they ought to, just on the
basis of blind chance evolution
and natural selection."
Now, that's a bit
of Darwin doubting
by one of the most
eminent scientists around.
And he's far from alone.
There are a lot of--
I like the way he puts
it too, because he's
a great believer in our natural
selection, but it bothers him,
and his nagging
thought that there's
got to be something that
doesn't quite add up.
And I'm going to
try to point out
what it is and then show
you how to get yourself out
of that puzzle.
And here's the way it could go.
How could a slow,
mindless process
build a thing that
could build a thing
that a slow mindless process
couldn't build on its own?
There does seem to be
something faintly miraculous
or pulling yourself up by
your own bootstraps there.
And my book is an attempt
to answer that question.
Well, of course,
you know the answer.
First, you evolve Alan Turing.
And then, he intelligently
designs a computer.
And we're home.
But how do we get
an Alan Turing?
How do we evolve an Alan Turing?
Well, the answer, of course,
is natural selection.
But this is the main
point of my book in a way,
not just natural
selection of genes.
We have to also talk
about cultural evolution
and the natural
selection of memes,
Richard Dawkins' idea
of cultural units
that replicate differentially.
And the ones that replicate
best are fitter, survive,
and make more, and
that human culture
is the medium, the
source, and ultimately
the power that makes somebody
like Alan Turing possible.
Well, this idea
suggests a question,
the question in my title.
So are brains computers?
I say, if brains are computers,
then who writes the software?
Well, let's pause and look
at whether our brains are
computers at all.
And some people think not.
Some insist that they aren't.
They're scientists,
such as Roger Penrose,
very clear about that in his
book, The Emperor's New Mind.
Gerry Edelman, the
late Nobel laureate--
I was a little puzzled by
Jerry's insistence that brains
were not computers, while he
modelled brains on computers
and used his models
to demonstrate
why a computer couldn't do
that sort of thing, which
was a problem that Gerry had.
But there's also Jaak
Panksepp, some of you may know,
an eminent neuroscientist
whose main area of interest
is emotion.
But there's philosophers
as well, of course.
John Searle comes
to mind, famously.
And your own Raymond Tallis.
And I'm not going to say any
more about either one of them
tonight.
I had my say elsewhere.
Because I want to talk about
computer phobia and, in fact,
two different varieties
of computer phobia,
which is my perhaps
somewhat rude term
for those who really don't like
the idea that our brains are
computers at all.
If brains aren't
computers, what are they?
Well, they're not pumps.
They're not factories.
They're not purifiers.
The task of brains is
to take information
in and yield control.
Of course, they're computers.
That's what a computer is.
It uses information
to control something.
This is not the kind of computer
that the people are imagining.
So I wanted to help you imagine
a different kind of computer,
an organic if you like or
an evolved computer, which
is what I think we
have between our ears.
So the mis-imagination
of computers
is something that
needs a diagnosis.
And I'm going to
try to provide it.
And I'm going to make
a new suggestion.
Well, it's a newish
suggestion, because others
have made it before.
But I want to remind you
that there have been a number
of attempts to say, well, brains
are sort of like computers,
but they aren't--
well, you know, they're
not made of silicon.
They're made of protein.
That's not what I
think is important.
They're not digital.
They're analogue.
That's slightly true,
but I don't think
that's the important point.
They're not serial.
They're parallel.
True, but that's not
what I want to focus on.
I want to focus on
something else entirely,
the difference between
cooperative and competitive
computers--
I mean, computers that
are made of cooperative
versus competitive parts.
So the default image
that most of us
have of computation
and certainly, say,
that Roger Penrose has is
that it's ultra efficient.
There's no waste motion,
no cross-purposes.
And there's redundancy
only for safety.
It's hierarchically organised,
where routines call subroutines
and the sub-routines answer.
It's all like a
well-oiled corporation
with chains of command
and control all the way
up and down.
And there is also
controlled prioritisation.
That is, there are, as it were,
built-in traffic cops that
decide what happens next.
You don't have any
fighting over that.
And there is competition
in the brain--
I mean, in computers.
But it's, as it were,
friendly opponent processes.
There's sort of tugs of war
that are carefully set up
in order to resolve some issue
in a tug of war sort of way.
But it's not, as it
were, deadly competition.
It's just for the sake of
finding a midpoint, usually,
something like that.
The computer scientist
Eric Baum has a nice name
for this kind of architecture.
He calls it the Politburo
architecture or Politburo
control, like the
old Soviet Union.
I want to compare that with
what one of my postdocs
once called brain wars.
In brain wars, we have real,
not notional competition.
It's even, in some cases,
a matter of life or death.
You have micro agents
with their own agendas--
neurons, astrocytes, glia cells.
But neurons are the ones
I'll concentrate on.
Tecumseh Fitch, a friend
of mine and colleague,
in the paper called
"Nano-Intentionality"
in Biology and Philosophy
a few years ago,
spells out the idea pretty
clearly that individual neurons
are agents.
And they're semi-autonomous.
And they do have agendas.
And that's very
different from what you
have in your digital computer.
So I want you to compare Marx,
to each according to his needs,
from each according
to his talents.
Compare that with
dog-eat-dog, free-for-all,
laissez-faire
capitalism, where there's
no central or higher control.
Cooperation does happen,
but it's not a precondition.
It's an intermittent
achievement.
OK?
Now, having presented
this stark contrast,
I do need to do a preemptive
noting of the irony, what
I'm not saying.
You might think,
uh oh, Dennett has
fallen in with the likes of
Ayn Rand and Milton Friedman
and laissez-faire capitalism.
No, no, no.
I'm not a fan of that
view of the economy.
But, still, centrally
planned economies don't work,
and neither do centrally
controlled, top-down brains.
Neither do centrally
controlled hierarchically
organised top-down brains.
Even the best
cognitive architectures
that have been developed
so far in cognitive science
have tended to be too
disciplined, too neat, too
not have the sort of
unruly competition
that I think now is essential
in an actual organic brain,
especially the human brain.
They're too bureaucratic,
you might say.
They have millions of
identical elements,
which is also important.
I didn't really appreciate
this until very recently,
when I was talking
with my good friend Rod
Brooks, a roboticist, an
extraordinary roboticist
with whom I worked for some
years on the Cog Project.
But we've had these models
of the brain ever since
the McCulloch-Pitts neurons,
which is one of the great
oversimplifications of all
times that came along--
I can't remember
the year right now,
but it was in the
'50s, I think, which
had these very simple elements,
logical neurons, which
emitted a single
branching output
and had bunches of
inputs that could either
have positive or negative
inhibitory or excitatory
attachments or stimuli inputs.
And then, they
summed the results,
and they either
fired or they didn't.
That was a brilliant
simplification.
And they're wonderful
little thinking tools.
But brains aren't like that.
This is mis-imagination.
And when we think
about computers,
we tend to imagine the
algorithms with which we
are somewhat
familiar, things you
know like Word and Photoshop
and Google Desktop, which
are all brilliantly
designed from the top down
with hierarchical control.
And if we compare those with
brains, just intuitively,
you think, nah.
Brains just aren't like that.
And you're right.
They aren't.
But that doesn't mean
they're not computers.
It just means they
aren't computers
with Politburo control and
top-down designed software.
They're not cold,
orderly, ultra efficient,
and authoritarian
machines, composed
of units that are
mindless little machines.
So I want to compare
those models with, oh,
how about the stock market.
Is the stock market a computer?
Is stock trading a
computational phenomenon?
Yeah.
It is.
And in fact, in a
way, the proof of that
is that those traders are being
replaced by machines right now.
And more and more stock
trading is done entirely
in the digital world.
And so whatever they were
doing all those years
was something that
could be easily done
by machines, because
machines are doing it now.
But now, let's look at neurons.
For once, I'm going to ask
you to look at a neuron.
Let's see if this is running.
Yes.
This is a little
looped bit of a film.
These are neurons in a dish.
And you see they're putting out
their little dendritic graspers
and looking around.
Here's another one.
Is it going to make
that connection?
No.
Yes.
So I want you to
replace the image
you have of a McCulloch-Pitts
neuron with these squiggly
little agents by the billions,
gathered in your brain
and faced with the task of
keeping life and limb together
for you.
Now, one thing that
you get immediately
when you start
thinking of neurons
in this more agent-like way
is you get a good account
of brain plasticity.
As you no doubt know, if
a little bit of your brain
is damaged, very often, not
always, but in many conditions,
the neighbouring parts of
the brain that are spared
can take over the work that was
being done by that part that's
now died or gone missing.
And some of the degrees of
versatility of brain tissue,
especially cortical
tissue, is just stunning.
And experiments show, for
instance, the famous Merzenich
experiments, where he
mapped the brain areas that
were involved in the
digits of a monkey
and then sutured the
fingers together,
so that the monkey
just had three digits,
and after a week or
so, went in and looked
at the areas that
were responsible
and saw that there
was a reorganisation
of the [? cortex. ?] It
wasn't as much work to do.
And so the neurons
were recruited
to do jobs for other purposes.
And the way to think
about this, I've decided,
is these are neurons
hungry for work.
And they've got to stay alive.
You may remember
a wonderful line
from Francois Jacobs, who once
said the dream of every cell
is to become two
cells, which is good,
true at first approximation,
but not true of neurons.
Pretty much, they're like mules.
They are the offspring
cells, but they're not
going to have any
offspring of their own.
So their dream is
just to stay alive.
But they got to stay alive.
They got to fight
for their energy.
And the only way to
fight for their energy
is to find useful work
that they can get paid for.
And so that's the kind
of energetic economy
that I think we have to
replace the Politburo model,
where all of this is taken
care of in a bureaucratic way.
Obviously, obviously, when
a bit of brain tissue dies,
there's no central personnel
director who reassigns
the neurons in
the neighbourhood.
That has to be figured out
in some sort of bottom-up way
by the neurons, not by some
boss neuron or commissar
in some part of the brain.
So there's no
central administrator
doing the reassignment at all.
But-- moreover, no two
neurons are exactly alike.
And this is the point that
I got from Rod Brooks, which
I mentioned earlier.
Rod is an unusual man with
many talents and many projects.
And one of his--
I don't know if he's
finished it yet.
I have spoken to him about this
for it's a couple of years,
I guess.
He was going to make what
I'm going to call a steampunk
computer, a pre-electronic
computer, no chips, not
even any vacuum tubes.
He was going to make a computer
out of relays and solenoids
and the sorts of
electrical switching
that you had before you had
the electronic age at all, just
to see if he could do it.
And of course, you can
make a computer out
of just about anything
if you're clever enough.
And so he set out to
make an actual computer.
He loves to solder and put wires
between things and so forth.
And he had a big room,
not quite as big as this.
But this is where he's
building the computer.
And of course, the
computer he was building
would have way, way less
than 1% of the power
and speed of your cell phone.
But it was an energy hog,
a giant electrical, not
electronic computer.
And I was talking with him
about the challenges of this.
He said, you know, the
hardest part of all
was getting all the flip-flops
exactly alike, simply
making them so exactly
similar that you
could get reliable
computation out of them.
The timing has to be precise.
And the response
has to be precise.
And that was a major challenge
for him as the builder of this.
And he said, we've been
taking for granted one
of the features of
the digital age, which
is that the manufacture,
the manufacturing
processes of chips
are just stunningly
high quality and regular.
You can have a bubble
memory with billions
of just test about exactly
identical to the atom
little memory units,
or flip-flops.
And without that,
the architecture
that you build on top
of them wouldn't work.
And we don't have
that between our ears.
We just don't.
So we have to rethink the
idea of computer architecture
to make an architecture
out of these
different, unruly, clueless,
little, multi-armed, blind
cells.
So a brain is not
made of units at all,
in those properties like what
you've got on your cell phone.
So now, I'm going to
show an image I've
shown often before,
because it so vividly makes
the point I want to make.
On the left, you see a termite
castle, an Australian termite
castle.
On the right, you
see, of course,
Antoni Gaudi's famous church
in Barcelona, Sagrada Familia.
They look stunningly alike.
And that's even no accident.
Even the interiors and
the structural members
have some striking similarities.
So here we have two artefacts,
both made by living things.
The one on the left
is made by termites.
The one on the right was
designed and built by Gaudi.
So here's a puzzle.
On the left, we have
bottom-up design.
On the right, we
have top-down design.
And I mean that just
about literally.
There's no boss termite.
There's no architect termite.
There's no blueprints.
There's no second in command
and echelons of command.
The termites are just doing
their individual thing.
And they don't know what
they're doing or why,
but they're doing it.
And the result is that
amazing structure.
That's bottom-up design
and construction.
Gaudi, on the other hand, was
a charismatic, megalomaniac,
creative genius with
blueprints, manifestos.
He had it all worked out
in advance in his head.
And he lorded it over
his second in command,
who lorded it over
the lieutenants, who
lorded it over the sergeants.
And down it went
to the people who
actually put the bricks together
or cut the stone and so forth.
So we have a stark
contrast, two different ways
of designing and building.
One is bottom-up.
I'm going to say, that's a
Darwinian way of building.
It's done by a lot of competent
but uncomprehending processes.
On the right, we have top-down,
intelligent design by Gaudi,
which is where it's mind first.
You come up with the idea.
You prove it's a good idea.
And off you go.
Of course, my other favourite
example of something that was
top-down design is
Turing's first computer.
He had the proof of concept.
Before they paid anything
to build the chassis
or put in the tubes, they
knew it was going to work,
because he proved it
was going to work.
And he knew exactly how it
was going to be put together.
They changed some things
along the way, of course.
So we have a stark
contrast here.
Now, here's the puzzle.
A termite colony
might contain, I
am told, up to 70 million
clueless termites.
Latest count is that your
brain contains about 86 billion
even more clueless neurons.
Now, here's the puzzle.
How do you get a Gaudi-type mind
out of a termite colony brain?
What you have between your ears
is 86 billion semi-autonomous,
clueless neurons.
Not a one of them knows
who you are or cares.
Somehow, that has
to be organised
into something that can do what
Gaudi did or what Turing did.
Well, when I was
thinking about this,
I was reminded first of all of
another great triumph of about
the same time as Turing.
And that's the
great K-25 building
at Oak Ridge in Tennessee,
built in record time
during World War II, part
of the Manhattan Project.
This is where they did the
gaseous diffusion of uranium
to make the weapons-grade
uranium for the atomic bomb.
When it was built,
it was, I think,
the largest building
in the world.
And over 12,000 workers
in round-the-clock shifts
worked there.
And they didn't know
what they were doing.
They were clueless about
They were trained to push
buttons and turn dials and look
at dials.
And they had no idea
what they were doing.
After the bomb was
dropped and they learned,
they were flabbergasted.
They didn't know they were--
they had no idea what
they were making there.
But now, think about it.
First of all, it is
possible to organise
armies of clueless operators
to perform some highly
sophisticated control task.
Witness Oak Ridge.
But who or what
does the organising?
And the answer in
the case of Oak Ridge
is that it was
top-down, intelligently
designed by a brilliant team
of physicists, engineers,
and a brilliant leader named
Leslie Groves, General Leslie
Groves.
So it's like Gaudi's church.
And it's like Turing's computer.
And it's like all good
old-fashioned AI programmes.
GOFAI was introduced by the
philosopher John Haugeland
some years ago.
And it stuck.
People in AI have
adopted his sort
of deliberately snide term,
"good old-fashioned AI."
It's the kind of AI that led to
the AI winter that is now over.
And we're now in
a new AI spring,
with all of the new bottom-up
computer processes that
are dazzling everybody today.
So good old-fashioned AI was
top-down, not bottom-up design.
This is a cartoon that
I made some years ago,
the walking encyclopaedia.
It was supposed to give you
an idea of what was involved.
This is the sort of
phony flow graph.
But we have a belief
box or belief fixation
box, and the planning
committee, and the action,
and the language
acquisition device
that Chomsky made famous.
And here's the lexicon.
Here's where the logic
is, perceptual analysis.
And you've got all these
departments interacting,
sending memos back and forth.
It's very, very bureaucratic
and very well organised,
very efficient,
and very brittle.
And it doesn't work.
And I say it doesn't
work because we
tried for several decades,
very, very smart people,
and more or less proved
that it didn't work.
So when we look at Oak Ridge,
we see it was top-down design,
and it did work.
But who knew what at Oak Ridge?
I tried to find out.
And as near as I
can tell, there's
still not much publicly
available information.
It's still clouded in security.
But General Leslie Groves knew.
And so did his
immediate staff and many
of those who reported to
them, and the head engineers
who designed the plant.
But probably the architects
that designed the building, just
the outer shell, had no
idea what the building
was going to have inside it.
It had a waterproof roof
and very strong supports
for various things.
But they didn't know
what was going in.
So I think there's a
sort of diminishing
level of comprehension
all the way down.
But for most of the people
that work there every day, not
a clue what they were doing.
And so we have to
face what we might
call the I can't see the woods
for the trees phenomenon.
There were levels of
granularity or insularity,
people who knew a little bit,
but only a few people who
pretty well knew
the whole thing.
The bird's eye view was
had by General Leslie
Groves and a few others.
And we can compare
that to, as it
were, the termites' view,
which is most of the work force
there had.
And the interesting thing is
that in the termite colony,
no termite or junta of top
termites sees the woods at all.
They just see the trees
they're working on.
And of course,
one effect of that
is that redesign
is achingly slow.
Takes evolutionary time
to get the termites
to do something else, because
there's nobody there that can--
to take a term from
good old-fashioned AI,
there's nobody there
who can do the blame
assignment and the
credit assignment
that you need to figure out
why the thing doesn't work.
They can't reverse engineer
their own engineer system,
which is what we can do.
Another effect is
with no boss, there's
no issue of what the
boss has access to,
to use a term from philosophy.
So there's no reason to
posit access consciousness
to the colony.
In other words, it's
not like anything
to be a termite colony.
Maybe like something
to be a termite.
But I think you'd
probably agree.
It's not like anything
to be a termite colony,
because there's no organisation
that gives access of any kind,
bird's eye view or otherwise,
to what's going on below.
Doesn't have to be.
So I can't prove that.
I think it's a highly
probable proposition.
And if you doubt
it, you might want
to consider questions
like what is it like
to be the Seattle Seahawks?
Not individual players on
the team, but the team.
Probably you'd say, no,
it's not like anything.
It's a bunch of individuals.
They may be very well organised,
but it's not like anything
to be the team.
And it's not like anything
to be a termite colony, which
would seem to lead to
the conclusion it's not
like anything to have a
brain or to be a brain.
What is it like to
be a human brain
would seem to give
the same answer.
But then, it sure seems
to be like something.
It's an important
and obvious fact.
There's no General Leslie
Groves in your brain.
And yet there seems to be.
Certainly, it seems to be
like something to be you
and that you that it seems to
be like something is in charge.
So now, we have the question,
how can we explain that there
seems to be a General
Leslie Groves in your brain,
when there isn't?
This is the view
that is often called,
or today often
called, illusionism,
that the whole idea
that consciousness
is a sort of useful illusion.
And I see by reviews today in
the New Statesman, an otherwise
very, very friendly
and positive review,
but the reviewer
just thinks this idea
that consciousness is
some kind of illusion,
it's just hopeless.
Well, I beg to differ.
But that's a long
story, and I'm not
going to be able to spend
a whole lot of time on it.
I've given you a hint about
what the answer might be.
So if we compare the
organisation of Oak Ridge
to the organisation
of the mind, brain,
and we compare it and GOFAI,
one of the things we see in this
diagram, we see you
have all these parts.
I can't leave it up there
while I ask my questions.
Does the LAD know its job is
acquiring a natural language?
No.
Does the belief box
understand its role
in informing the
other departments?
No.
Only the AI designers know
the functions of the parts.
The intelligent designers
off on the side.
GOFAI is a top-down
intelligent design.
Now, this is not the
threadbare criticism
that everything
these AI systems know
is what the creators
installed in them.
No.
Garbage in, garbage out.
Nothing in the programme that
isn't known by the programme
creators.
That's just not true.
Even of those systems
it wasn't true.
Many of those systems go
way beyond their creators
in what they know.
This is a point that the
design of the architecture that
supports this knowledge
is top-down design.
It's hierarchical and efficient.
So actually that's just the
first kind of computer phobia
that I wanted to try to alert
you to and suggest a runaround.
Yes, our brains are
computers, but they're
more like termite colonies
than like your laptop.
And that's all right.
They can still be
computers, because
competitive
architectures are still
computational architectures.
The next source
of computer phobia
is, but the mind isn't software.
And I have to admit that
even some of my best friends
think I'm nuts on this score,
among them Steve Pinker
and Paul Churchland.
But they haven't convinced me.
And I'm going to defend the idea
that, in fact, our minds are
software running on that
termite colony brain.
And it's the software
that distinguishes us
from other animals.
First of all, let's get rid
of some obsolete objections.
Where are the floppy discs?
The brain doesn't have
RAM, and the CPU software
consists of bit strings.
Software is hardware specific
at the level of compiled code.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's not what
I'm talking about.
I'm talking about something
a little different.
more like Java applets.
What's a Java applet?
You use them every day.
You don't know it probably.
They're apps.
Or they're like apps.
They run on your hardware.
And they can be written
by a software designer who
doesn't need to know what
kind of hardware you have,
whether you're running it on
a cell phone, or on a Mac,
or on an IBM computer, or a
Linux computer, on Windows,
or Mountain Lion.
It doesn't matter.
It'll run, as they
say, on all platforms.
That's not strictly true,
but on all that matter.
It runs on lots of different--
Java is a computer programming
language it runs on.
You don't have to specify what
the underlying hardware is.
Java takes care of that for you.
So one who writes Java
applets has no need
to know the fine
details of the hardware,
because installed on your
hardware is something
called the JVM, the
Java Virtual Machine.
Now, that's software.
But it's software
that is specifically
designed to fit on the
hardware in question.
And it protects that
hardware from malicious use,
among other things.
But it also permits Java
applets to be downloaded off
the internet, for instance,
and run on your computer.
Now, I want to draw
your attention.
So the Java virtual machine has
to be installed before the Java
applet will run.
In fact, the Java virtual
machine on your cell phone
or on your laptop has probably
been updated several times
in the last week without
you even knowing it.
You've gone online
to get something,
and you need a new
version of Java VM.
And so it's
automatically downloaded
from whatever site you're on.
And it takes care
of the problem.
How many of you had a message
come on your screen say,
will you accept a Java update?
Some people set their machines
to make sure that they always
know when that's happening.
But in general, you don't know.
So now, I want to draw
attention to this.
One who writes Java
applets has no need
to know the fine
details of the hardware.
Now, what's the
importance of that?
What am I doing right now?
I'm talking to you all.
Each of you has installed
a version of the EVM
on your neck-top.
That's the English
virtual machine.
I don't have to know the
details of the hardware
between your ears.
I can count on the fact
that you have the EVM,
and so you can run
the code that I'm
downloading to you as we speak.
Now, that's, of course,
an oversimplification.
But the main idea is the
one that I want to stress,
is that the beauty
of having language
is it permits us to share
ways of doing things
that we wouldn't otherwise
be able to share,
because we can tell
each other about them.
Of course, you can also
show people without telling.
But the capacity to
talk is really important
to make a culture cumulative.
These are thinking tools.
Words are a good example
of thinking tools.
Each word is its own little
tool, a way of doing something,
a way of referring to something,
remembering something,
labelling something, et cetera,
and a way of pronouncing
something.
And I love the line from
Goethe, "when ideas fail,
words come in very handy."
That's important to
remember, that sometimes you
can use a word to great
effect without really having
much of an idea what it means.
And sometimes, that's
actually useful.
Other thinking tools are
numbers, diagrams, maps,
methods, and intuition pumps.
My last book was a collection
of more than 70 thinking tools,
most of them were what
I call intuition pumps.
They're a little fancier
than an individual word.
They're a way of thinking
about something, which
is worth adding to your kit.
Notice, by the way, that
what I've just done right now
is I've downloaded an
app to your neck-top.
If you didn't have
it before, you now
have the idea of words
and other cultural items
being like apps
that are downloaded
to your neck-tops, where they
can give you new competences
that you didn't have
before, in exactly the way
your cell phone or your laptop
can pick up new competences
by downloading software.
I think it's actually a very
significant and deep parallel.
There's lots of reasons.
There's lots of disanalogies
worth enumerating
and considering.
Any rate, I've
given you the app.
You're stuck with it.
And it's what makes
possible what I've
called the MacCready Explosion.
You remember the eukaryotic
revolution led pretty soon
to what's known as the
Cambrian Explosion, which
was a incredible diversity
of life that grew out
of the rise of the eukaryotic
cell, which itself arose when
two prokaryotic cells
bumped into each other
and decided neither
one ate the other
or disassembled the other.
In fact, they joined forces and
became a more powerful thing.
That was the first great
technology transfer
in the history of evolution.
The second was much more recent.
It was when our
brains began to be
invaded by memes, another
great technology transfer.
You didn't have to invent
the wheel yourself.
You got that for free.
It was in the culture.
You didn't have to invent
calculus or cost benefit
analysis or French or English.
You didn't have to
invent any of those.
The software was already
available and almost free.
All you have to do, download
it to your neck-top.
So MacCready, the late, great
Paul MacCready calculates--
calculated, died recently--
that if you go back 10,000 years
to the dawn of
agriculture, and you
put all the human beings,
plus all their pets,
plus their livestock on
one side of the scale,
and you put all
the other animals,
terrestrial vertebrates on
the other side of the scale,
10,000 years ago, the percentage
by mass of the humans,
plus their domesticated
animals, he
calculated at a fraction of 1%.
So what is it today?
Some of you have heard
me talk about this.
Anybody hazard a guess?
Is it 10%?
20%?
60%?
80%?
98%.
We have swamped the
planet with our cattle
and our other domesticated
animals and ourselves.
This is one of the most vivid
and fast biological phenomena
that's ever occurred in the
history of life on the planet.
And it's taken only
10,000 years, which
is just a eye blink of time.
This is what MacCready
says about this.
"Over billions of years,
on a unique sphere,
chance has painted a
thin covering of life--
complex, improbable,
wonderful, and fragile.
Suddenly we humans have grown
in population, technology,
and intelligence to a
position of terrible power.
We now wield the paintbrush."
Now, all this happened way
too fast to be due to genes.
There have just not been enough
generations in the last 10,000
years for there to be really
major revolutions in our genes.
If you could time machine a
person from 10,000 years ago
to today, they might have
some disease vulnerabilities
that we don't have.
But otherwise,
they'd do just fine.
Give him a shave and a
haircut dress them up,
and they'd pass for one of us.
But I'll give you another
example, which some of you
may know about, some of you
may not-- the Flynn effect.
The Flynn effect
is perfectly real.
And IQ is up just
in the last century.
The average in 1932 would be 80.
That is to say, IQ is on a
scale, so 100 is average.
If you're above 100,
you're above average.
If you're below 100,
you're below average.
But if you give the very
same tests that people--
where the average
was 100 just in 1932,
you give the very same
test to people today,
the people who scored 100
then would score 80 now.
This is a robust, clear effect.
We're getting smarter.
And it's not due to genes.
It cannot be due to genes.
There hasn't been
anywhere near enough time.
So what's changed?
The short answer, you
can't do much carpentry
with your bare hands.
And you can't do much
thinking with your bare brain.
That was something
that my friend Bo
Dahlbom said a few years ago.
I thought, boy, that nails it.
You can't do much carpentry
with your bare hands.
You can't do much thinking
with your bare brain.
A termite colony
is a bare brain.
Gaudi had a well-equipped
brain, full of thinking tools.
And where did he get his tools?
Well, here's the wrong answer,
coming from Freeman Dyson.
"Technology is a gift of God.
After the gift of
life, it is perhaps
the greatest of God's gifts.
It is the mother of
civilizations, of arts,
and of sciences."
Everything but the first
sentence I heartily endorse.
But come on, Freeman.
Technology is not a gift of God.
So the long answer is
that cultural evolution
designed thinking
tools that impose
novel structures on our brains.
These are evolved
virtual machines.
Virtual machines are
machines made out
of information, ways of doing
things on your neck-top.
And this leads to a
chicken and egg puzzle.
Did evolved mind
tools make us smarter?
Or did we evolve to become
smart enough to make mind tools?
And as usual with
chicken and egg problems,
the answer is yes.
The effect, though, of human
culture, which started slow
and then sped up greatly, is
that human cultural evolution
has itself evolved.
And I owe the next slide
to my friend, Matt Ridley.
it's his slide, which I do love.
On the left, you see
an actual hand axe.
Our ancestors made these without
any apparent change in design
for a million years.
On the right is a mouse.
It was designed by
Douglas Engelbart.
And it's on the
verge of extinction
after only a few decades in use.
That's a nice measure of the
speed of cultural evolution.
So if we think of our minds
as software, if we think
of words as virtual machines--
well, why not?
Well, what is a word made of?
Sounds?
Ink?
No, no, no, no.
Words are more
abstract than that.
My colleague Ray Jackendoff
in his wonderful book,
Foundations of Language, says
that words are semi-autonomous
informational structures--
sounds like software to me--
with multiple roles
to play in cognition.
That's what a word is.
And just the way you can copy
software and move it around
to other platforms, so you
can do the same with words.
Think of the diversity of words.
Tens of thousands of words
in many different languages--
where did they all come from?
In thousands of languages, could
they have a common ancestor?
Yeah, they could.
In fact, there's
interesting attempts
to trace back, trace
back, trace back
to find a common ancestor of
even the most diverse languages
on the planet.
This is all controversial.
And of course, there's
no written records there,
so it has to be
very conjectural.
But at least we can trace
back a lot of the languages
a very long way and
know that they evolved,
that the words in them
evolved from those languages
and often jumped
to other languages.
Did those words have
intelligent designers?
No.
Words are brilliantly designed.
They're great, infectious,
replicable, complex
informational structures.
But they're designed by
natural selection, not
genetic natural selection, but
cultural natural selection.
You don't get your
words with your genes.
You move a baby born to
Chinese parents to London,
and that baby is going to
learn English, not Chinese.
Words have evolved.
Darwin himself noted
that in a famous passage.
He saw a striking resemblance
between the lineages
of words and languages
and the theme
that he was developing
in The Origin of Species.
So we have phylogenetic
trees like the tree of life.
And we have glossogenetic
trees, which
show the evolution
of languages--
the Romance language coming
from Latin, for instance.
I don't need to
show those to you.
So now, then, what is a meme?
The other day I went and
looked on the online Collins
dictionary and got
a rude awakening.
"A meme is something such as
a video, picture, or phrase
that a lot of people sent to
each other on the internet."
Goes on, "short for mimeme,
both coined by R Dawkins, 1941,
British biologist?"
Not the best source
of information.
But indeed, the word was
coined by Richard Dawkins,
the author of The Selfish
Gene, in his book in 1976.
And one thing that's clear
is that the meme meme
has gone viral.
Just a few days ago, on the
television show Jeopardy,
an America quiz show,
the very same quiz show
in which IBM's Watson beat
the human best contestants
of all times handily--
on Jeopardy, the term is used
without mention of Dawkins
and without definition
for the contestants.
So they had a whole
board of questions
about different kinds of memes.
I'm not going to
give you a chance
to look at all those categories.
And nobody said
boo about the fact
that here the categories
were all memes.
Is this what Dawkins meant when
he coined the term in 1976?
Uh, no.
Not at all.
But I want to compare it
to another scientific term,
the Big Bang.
I went online to check
the Big Bang, which,
of course, was coined by Fred
Hoyle a few years earlier,
astronomer.
And what I found was
that the first few pages
of Google on Big Bang Theory
were about the television
sitcom.
Had to go to third page
before I got anything
about Fred Hoyle and the
origins of the universe.
So "the Big Bang" still
means what Hoyle meant.
The question is
does "meme" still
mean what Dawkins meant
when he coined the term?
Well, let's look at Dawkins
version very quickly.
He says, "I think that
a new kind of replicator
has recently emerged
on this very planet.
It is staring us in the face.
It is still in its infancy,
still drifting clumsily
in its primaeval soup.
But already it's achieving
evolutionary change
at a rate which leaves the
old gene panting far behind.
The raw soup is the
soup of human culture."
Well, now, what
do internet memes
have to do with evolution
by natural selection?
So has Dawkins'
term been hijacked?
Has this meaning of
meme gone extinct?
Many, especially those
in the humanities
who hate the the idea of memes,
fervently hope so, I think.
And they think this was
a suitably, fittingly
unrespectable demise
of an abhorrent idea.
Well, really?
What's so bad about it?
What's not to like in
the idea of a meme?
To see why so many
are opposed to it,
we must look at the key features
of Dawkins' concept of memes.
Memes are replicators
like genes.
Culture evolves by a process
of blind, purposeless,
foresightless natural selection,
not by intelligent design.
And differential
replication or reproduction
is the key, not human genius.
That's what people don't like.
They don't like the idea
that human culture is not
to be due to the authorship of
human geniuses over the age.
That's one of the things
they don't like about it.
Well, you see, internet
memes have authors.
They are intelligently
designed, some of them,
by self-styled meme smiths.
There are even
competitions to see who
can design the most viral meme.
This is intelligent design
run riot on the internet.
Are these not such profound
differences from Dawkins' memes
that they must count as a
different type or species
altogether?
No.
And the key is in
the word "species."
Let me explain.
Are dinosaurs extinct?
How many say so?
No, they're not
extinct, in one sense.
Birds are direct
descendants of dinosaurs.
There's probably a few
hundred dinosaur descendants
within 100 yards of where
we're sitting right now.
They're not much
like the originals.
But they are direct
descendants of the dinosaurs.
That's well-established
biological fact.
And it was a gradual
process, which,
of course, is very important.
Very gradual change
we can believe in.
Well, now, the question
is, is culture different?
Did culture evolve by
Darwinian processes?
Or did it arrive by
some sort of Big Bang,
the way Freeman Dyson suggested?
And we want to put in
yet another gradualism.
Cultural evolution
happened gradually.
The first memes were
adopted unwittingly
by hominids that didn't know
what they were doing or why.
They were more like
termites, in this regard.
Reflectiveness about
memes came much later.
And what's happened is
the de-Darwinization
of cultural evolution.
It started very Darwinian, very,
very much like termite design.
And it's become ever
more intelligent,
as human culture has provided
ever greater bounties of tools
for the intelligent designers
to put in their heads
and then use to think
of intelligent designs.
So memes.
Dawkins' list included tunes,
ideas, catchphrases, clothes,
fashions, ways of making
pots or building arches.
So memes are ways
of doing things.
The difference between memes
and instincts is simple.
Instincts are ways that are
passed through the germ line,
through the genes.
Memes are ways that are passed
otherwise, perceptually,
socially.
At this point, I know
some people think,
do memes even exist?
I've encountered this often.
Somebody will say, I don't
know if memes even exist.
Prove to me that memes exist.
They seem like flights
of fancy, just metaphors.
Well, now, I want to
consider-- how many of you
would accept this statement?
Hands up those who agree.
I don't see any hands going up.
Well, what are words?
Dogs are a kind of
mammal or a kind of pet.
Words are a kind of what?
Sound, sign, symbol?
What they are is a kind of meme.
What kind?
The kind that can be pronounced.
That's what distinguishes
them from all other memes.
So they're items of
culture that spread
by being reproduced,
differentially reproduced,
sometimes with
changes or mutations.
They form lineages, differential
replication, and extinction.
Memes evolve just as animals
and plants and viruses do.
Viruses aren't
alive, but they sure
do evolve by natural selection.
So you don't have to
be alive to evolve
by natural selection, which
is a pretty good thing,
because words aren't alive.
But they evolved by
natural selection.
Memes are not alive.
They are subject to
natural selection.
I have a phrase for
what viruses are.
They're nucleic
acid with attitude.
That means something
about their shape
gives them the
power, the competence
to provoke their own replication
when they get inside a cell.
Memes are virtual machines,
software with attitude.
They provoke their own
replication in various ways,
for various reasons.
They compete for transmission
and also for local influence.
What are memes made of?
They're made of information.
I'm going to speed
up a little bit.
I want to get to a punchline.
People think genes
are made of DNA.
No, no, no.
Genes are the information
that are carried by DNA codes.
Poems aren't made of ink.
Right?
You can send a poem to
somebody with some ink,
but poems are not made of ink.
And genes are not made
of DNA, although that's
their normal vehicle
of expression,
but not the only one.
When you get your
genome coded, when
you get your genome
sequenced, you
get a list of A, C,
G, and T, so forth.
Those are your genes
in a different medium.
So words are the
best memes that we
have that make good examples,
because they're countable.
They have clear lineages.
They mutate in meaning
and in pronunciation
and grammatical role.
And they compete
for space in brains,
the way bacteria and viruses
compete for space in bodies.
Well, if words are
the best memes,
why didn't Dawkins say so?
Well, in fact, he did say this.
"The survival or preservation
of certain featured words
in the struggle for existence
is natural selection."
And that's Darwin sort of
prophesying Dawkins on memes.
So words are brilliantly
designed, but not by us.
Phonemes, one of
natural selection's most
brilliant inventions--
I'm going to pass over
this very swiftly.
I think I've run out of time.
But first of all,
I want you to ask,
what counts for
replication in words?
Is it physical similarity?
Or is it something else?
Is it physical resemblance?
Well, let's look.
Cat, cat, cat, cat, cat,
cat, cat, cat, cat, cat, cat.
How similar were
those physical things?
Not very.
But they were all tokens
of the type "cat."
And you recognise
them easily as such.
That's because
they're digitised.
They are orally
digitised as phonemes
and orthographically digitised
as letters of the alphabet.
And this is what makes
high fidelity transmission
and replication in
culture possible,
in the same way that the
four letter code of DNA
permits the high fidelity
replication of living
organisms.
So if words are virtual
machines, who designed them?
Evolution, cultural evolution.
And how are they installed?
They're installed by repetition.
I'm going to go
over that quickly.
Go in more detail in my book.
How did cultural
evolution start?
Well, we started with the
genetic information highway
that is used by all lifeforms.
And then, a second
information highway
evolved by natural selection.
And that was social learning.
And when you have species
where the children hang around
with their parents,
because they're dependent--
they're altricial,
rather than precocial.
Precocial species, they sort
of hit the ground running.
If they need parental
care, then they're
going to be hanging
around their parents.
This gives opportunities
for information transfer
that would not
otherwise be there.
And social learning
is also abetted
by other adaptations, some of
which are quite easy to see.
Well, there's prolonged
infancy, which I just mentioned.
And then, there's
imprinting on parents,
which is also seen in
geese and ducks and birds,
as Tinbergen and
Lorenz famously shown.
But now, I want to show you
our nearest living relative.
And I want to
compare her to her.
What's the most
striking difference?
The sclera, the
whites of the eyes.
Why do we have the whites
of our eyes when our nearest
neighbours and the
orangutans don't?
Because it enhances the
capacity for gaze monitoring,
for seeing where
mum's looking, which
enhances the capacity for
shared attention, which
is, by general agreement
now, among people working
on learning and
cultural evolution,
is a key feature of
transmission of information
from parents to children.
But once you got parent-children
information passing,
then that's a highway that can
be parasitised, just the way
the internet, which was
designed for transmitting
classified information
about military projects,
has been parasitised by
internet memes, pornography,
all the rest of the things
that we use the internet for.
So a second information
highway, once it's in place,
it can be invaded in what
Boyd and Richerson, who
are the leading theorists,
call oblique transmission.
And they call these things
that are obliquely transmitted
rogue cultural variants.
Another word for rogue
cultural variants is memes.
They choose not to use the word
"meme" for various reasons.
But that's what they are.
Other theories of culture
need memes just as much
as Dawkins' and mine, even if
they don't call them memes.
They call them traditions
or methods or ideas or ways
or non-genetically transmitted
adaptations and so forth.
But they're all memes.
Memes take advantage of the
information highways built
by evolution for many species
and enhance in our species
and our species only.
Francis Crick once propounded
Orgel's second rule.
Evolution is cleverer
than you are.
Obviously, he doesn't
mean intelligent design
with a capital I, D. He means
that evolution, a completely
mindless, purposeless
process, nevertheless
can generate designs
of cunning virtuosity
and brilliant efficiency that
is hard for human engineers,
human intelligent
designers to match.
Well, intelligent
design now exists.
We have people like,
oh, Bach and Turing
and Gaudi, wonderful examples
of intelligent designers.
And intelligent design is
becoming ever more intelligent,
thanks to all the new
thinking tools that we're
creating all the time.
And this has some
surprising implications.
So finally, I just want
to finish off this topic.
So is this a
reductio ad absurdum?
Internet memes, is this an
embarrassment to Dawkins?
Is it a reductio ad absurdum
of his concept of memes?
I don't think so.
An intelligently designed meme
is a contradiction in terms?
No.
Or so what?
Here's another
contradiction in terms.
A splittable atom.
After all, the word "atom"
originally means unspittable.
We learned that you
can split an atom.
We didn't change the term.
And we learned that you can
intelligently design a meme.
And they belong to the same
class, if not the same species,
as the original memes.
They're just evolved under
different evolutionary regimes.
So internet memes are
actually prime examples
of Dawkins' memes.
They replicate because they
can, not because they're
necessarily good for us, not
because they're good for us.
And they have fitness
independent of ours.
They spread so fast.
Tell me if there's
anybody in this room who
thinks that internet
memes are an enhancement
to the genetic fitness of
the people that make them?
You have another
thing coming if you
think that's likely to be true.
They're cultural junk,
not cultural treasure.
Neither their authors nor
their vectors-- that is,
those who spread them--
need to understand why they are
doing what they're doing, just
like spreading cold germs.
One of my favourite examples
is the Polynesian canoe.
In an article by
Rogers and Ehrlich,
they quote a French philosopher.
He was not writing
about Polynesian canoes,
but, in fact, about
French fishing boats.
And he says, "every boat is
copied from another boat.
Let's reason as follows
in the manner of Darwin.
It is clear that a
very badly made boat
will end up on the bottom
after one or two voyages
and thus never be copied.
One could then say,
with complete rigour,
that it is the sea herself
who fashions the boats,
choosing those which function
and destroying the others."
If it comes back, copy it.
That's natural selection.
The copiers don't have
to understand why it's
a better boat than the others.
They simply trust the
fact it came back.
Don't fix what ain't broke.
Copy it.
So when we usually
think of culture,
we think about the grand,
highest levels of culture,
where we have the high culture--
opera and great art in museums
and so forth, which we
spend good money to maintain
and preserve.
And we very carefully bequeath
it to the next generation,
and so forth.
But in addition to
all that great stuff--
and that includes all the
science too, of course--
there's all the junk.
And it's just as much
a part of human culture
as the high culture is.
And we want to have
a perspective which
treats all of the culture
in the same diagram,
in the same picture.
And that's what we can do.
Memes have their own fitness.
And the memes-eye view
provides a general perspective
on cultural evolution,
not just on the treasures,
and not just the things
noticed or valued,
not just the actual inventions.
We comprehend less
than we think.
And that's one of the features
that I develop in the book.
We don't need to comprehend
many of the things in culture
that we benefit
from, in the same way
that a butterfly with
eye spots on its wings
doesn't need to understand
that this is really
good at scaring away the birds.
It benefits from having the
spots and opening up its wings.
It doesn't have to understand
it to be the beneficiary.
And similarly, we don't
have to understand
many of our cultural traditions
that we endorse, spread, keep.
They may be very good for us.
But we don't have
to understand it.
So we're living in the
age of intelligent design.
It has become ever
more top-down.
And we even have things
like GM food and people
like Craig Venter.
But now, we're entering the
age of post-intelligent design.
In many fields,
intelligent designers
are exploiting the truth
of Orgel's second rule.
Evolution is cleverer
than you are.
We have genetic algorithms
and deep learning
and evolutionary architecture
and nanotechnology
of various sorts.
And all of these are
Darwin-esque, evolution-like,
bottom-up, mindless,
competent processes
that sift through
enormous amounts of data
and come up with new ideas.
So now, let's recall
my earlier question.
How could a slow,
mindless process
build a thing that
could build a thing
that a slow mindless process
couldn't build on its own?
We've come full circle.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
Is it actually true
that nobody really
wants to talk about
that in science,
because it's not a
third-person phenomenon,
or am I missing something?
Why is there never talk about
the most important thing
in human biology,
in brain science?